eh bien il ya des gens qui lui ont
ramené un bel organe mais à toujours
plus de bravo bravo les cherry est fait
là alors venez venez venez venez alors
regardez tous les gens qui ont ramené
des vélos et alors mais ça c'est le vélo
de philippe vandel
alors jetez votre course alors monsieur
donc alors attendre aussi out vous
offrez ce vélo à philippe bordas
l'exacte bon bah c'est vrai c'est le
vôtre
exactement anthony qui manquait de vélo
donc j'étais son ordinateur je suis vite
fait en dix minutes j'étais là et j'ai
importé et bah écoute et on va faire la
table par ici on va partir de là clovis
esker vélo pour commission dans les
vallées et sur la rive on allait bel et
bien sûr je pars avec toi voilà philippe
vandel il a gagné un vélo dans
l'histoire voilà ça lui fait plaisir
je voudrais remercier tous les gens qui
sont venus merci des cherry on va faire
notre départ du tour de france parce que
demain c'est la sortie de la grande
boucle et oui sur vos écrans avec le
risque cardiaque avec arrêt habitants
merci les chéris allez c'est parti on y
va suivez moi j'ai maintenant dans ce
joli dans les partis c'est parti les
gars bossent et ça devient vraiment
n'importe quoi
on fait le tour on fait le tour
attention on fait le dos merci à toute
attaque avec nous c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi que l'on dise merci
d'avoir été là yukio nice il faudra
frapper je vois plus comme mr fait rare
pour aller retour merci à tous et c'est
vraiment alors ça sa série fera dans les
annales de la télévision garcia